What I have in front here, is the
brand-new Refraktor
This is a Decepticon that you can see. He
comes in robot form and if you look at
the box itself, he is in robot form but
if you look in the background
he changes into the space gun but for
folks who are not familiar with his real
mode it's actually in camera and the
issue is when it comes to the actual product or manual.
You realize you can transform it into a space gun.
but there's no instructions into
changing him into an actual camera.
So here's a quick guide into how I'm going
to change from robot mode into a camera.
so I have here Refraktor in his robot
mode so what we are going to do first is.
Take off the button here looks like a shutter
and you're gonna turn his head around
like so put them in and then we move
these back. What's important is the
swivel here and to ensure that his hand
grips go into these small little holes,
and once that's done,
he's put them at the wrist if you can
see here and just move them up that's
pretty much it when it comes to the arms
and what we're gonna do now we're gonna
rotate the waist so that his front is now at back.
Rotate the legs and pull out his skis here.
Make sure the skis are on the outside
and what we are going to do now...
Is put them in, so to slot them in nicely,
and if it's correct it should come up like this
and do the same on the other side
Pushes down and if it's all correct
should be able to tap everything nicely
in together like so. There you have it
this is the easiest transformation to
change refractor into his camera mode
and in order to do so we'll need to have
three of them.
Which is why we have these boxes here.
Now we are going to change these guys from this mode (transformer) into this.
Now that we have all three in order, it's time to assemble them.
The front looks like this
and these will be the back.
If you look closely, there are nice tabs that snaps in place. Then this is how we put them together!
Do the same for the 3rd piece.
Pretty sturdy... so this is how camera looks
like, not quite that yet, because you do
have the camera lens and the tripods.
We are going to put the camera lens together now.
Straightforward just clip them together.
and there we have the camera lens.
Make sure every section is tight.
and figure out how to slot it in.
There we go...
Small little knobs there to fit it all in.
Get in and there we have the camera
itself. Does it look like a camera from the back?
It's missing a shutter
so we can put it here.
and you got your camera. Pretty good actually
so this tripod the tripod together
Let's put it on the tripod...
Put the tripod together...
Flip it around.
See these nice little knobs here.
So once you put it together, you still need this
additional part here..
and you see the tabs go into these here
so I'm going to put it in.
okay and you can actually put him into
this spot when you're done this is how
Refraktor should look like
instead of it's very lame space gunman..
I think overall it's a very nice figure and
I guess this is the most affordable option,
when it comes to getting the Refraktor
series compared to the other third parties
and Hasbros' really done a
really good job here.
Awesome!